okay so the book of boba fett episode 6
is now out and the new entry is packed
with easter eggs things you missed and
also lots of hidden details the finale
is just one week away and throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down the entire thing and also
discussing what we think could be
happening next week full spoilers ahead
so if you haven't had a chance to check
it out then i highly recommend that you
take an r2 detour and i'll c3po you
later what also smash a thumbs up button
here if you've been following us for the
last six weeks as it's the best way to
support the channel and i'll always
think yoda best without the way thank
you for clicking this i get away with
murder don't uh now let's get into the
book of boba fett
okay so last week showed things from the
perspective of the mandalorian and we
watched as he tried to master the dark
saber after the armorer discovered that
he'd removed his helmet she announced
that he was no longer a mandalorian and
now was just a man now mandal returned
to tatooine and along with fury lover
pelimoto the pair built a new ship for
him out of an n1 starfighter after a
joyride that defied beggar's canyon
belief he returned to the hangar to find
fenix shand who was here to hire some
muscle that takes us into episode 6
which sort of brings all the pieces
together before setting things up for
the finale next week now the episode is
written by dave filoni who you'll
probably know as being behind the clone
wars together with john favreau the pair
have helped to show this is the way on
disney plus with classic after classic
now we open with the pikes out in the
desert of tatooine surrounded by
moisture towers they have a speeder
which looks like the one hand rolled in
at the start of solo star wars story and
also container that plays into the end
of the episode you might recognize these
from star wars lore and they actually
were an ice cream maker that popped up
in the original trilogy since then
they've sort of been used as a ninja and
have become a mainstay in the franchise
now the group are interrupted by the
martial of this territory koban van
refrigeration last seen in episode one
of season two of the mandalorian it's an
awesome way to kick start the cameo
packed entry which features a number of
big names it's clear that people just
don't take too kindly to the pikes in
these parts and he sends them a warning
that if they run spice rumors palgo that
they'll wind up in a ditch a sarlacc
ditch if you will now he tells them to
leave a chair that the pike says his
worth more than the entire town and this
is filled with the narcotic spice spice
is basically a drug in the star wars
universe that was used in things like
death sticks and it was based on the
substance of the same name from june
some of that franchise it's heavily
sought after and it also has
hallucinogenic qualities george lucas
stated that he was heavily inspired by
june and maybe the pike should just go
to arrakis or something as this is
boba's planet well it's it's also meant
to be his show but he's not in it that
much is he now they don't want to let
bygones be by guns and eventually send a
bounty hunter after him which ties into
the title from the desert comes a
stranger we'll talk about this later on
but after the title screen we jump back
to mandel piloting his new craft at this
point we see r2d2 scanning the area and
he of course recognizes this starfighter
as he flew one with anakin mando
announces that he's here to see luke and
grogu and we get a ton of scenes with
them as we watch the former training the
ladder our two last appeared alongside
luke in the mandalorian season 2 and we
initially get a fake out that looks like
a rock levitating due to the force this
brings up similar iconography to when
luke did it in empire strikes back but
alas it's just a smile-like droid
building the jedi temple jumped to a
legion of these putting together a
structure that looks very similar the
ones on act 2 in the last jedi the
temple itself was also briefly shown in
force awakens and i believe that this is
what they're putting together this was
very much the beginning of luke's jedi
academy which as we know from the sequel
trilogy is of course doomed now did i
ever tell you the tragedy of darth
plague sorry luke's jedi academy it's
not a story disney will fully tell you
in one movie however the next part of
the video we will be going through what
happened now after the battle of endor
luke set out to rebuild a jedi order and
took on his first student lair we saw
this through our flashbacks and rise of
skywalker and on the last day of her
training she sensed the death of her son
due to this she chose to end it and
somewhat cut itself off from the force
i'm not sure how the timeline will work
on this as grogu is said to be the first
student but this is likely referring to
the school itself rather than the first
person he trained luke then spent some
time finding four sensitive children and
he also teamed up with law santaka a
sort of historian and church of the
force member you might also remember him
as being the guy who gets oofed at the
start of force awakens you know super
important played by max von sidao
completely wasted the guy's talent
anyway during the events of the
mandalorian luke would be led to grogu
after his meditation on tithe on and he
would take him for training at his new
academy during this time luke would also
be researching the jedi order and he
spent years finding trinkets in order to
understand the history of the jedi in
the sith this included an earthing the
wayfinder on persana and one of the more
important devices he would come across
was the compass on paleo this showed up
in the star wars battlefront 2 story and
it would allow him to find specific jedi
locations he would even come across
remnants of the great tree that grew at
the heart of the jedi temple on
coruscant and the guy spent several
decades unearthing lots of things liu
could form an academy of his own the one
that we see being built in this entry
that was later burned down by kylo ren
before the fall luke would conduct
teachings to the new apprentices and ben
was placed in luke's care to be taught
how to use his raw force power in order
to keep him safe from the mysterious
snoke however ben would be brought on
missions as seen in the rise of kylo ren
comics and he would have his mind
twisted by snoke luke would then
question if ben deserved to live or die
which ben kind of took badly and it led
to an almighty falling out between uncle
and nephew luke then retreated to actu a
bless you and the first jedi temple
believing the jedi order had been a
failure he would then attempt to hide
and he killed himself off from the force
before he was found by rey now we don't
know what grogu's fate is in all of this
but there is potential like come the
next episode he will choose to be a
mandalorian and that he'll escape the
perch this would also set up mandalorian
season 3 in which the pair could be
reunited and yeah i think come the end
of the episode he will choose the gift
from his dad now after mano gets a bench
built for him he has to sit and wait for
the jedi to reveal themselves much like
when luke reached dagobah cut to luke
and grogue training and i'm so glad that
they fixed the former's face there was
something slightly off about him in the
mandalorian but here he looks way way
better if you cast your mind back to the
aftermath of season 2 then you might
remember that there were several people
who put out videos fixing the
character's face and we do know that one
of these actually got hired by lucasfilm
the deep fake works way better and it's
difficult to tell it apart from a real
actor they even have this scar above his
lip and in case you don't know mark
hamill was actually in a car accident
after a new hope he had to have
extensive surgery and due to his face
being slightly different they used the
whomper and empire to sort of explain it
away this was before the internet though
so i don't know if anyone noticed or
cared because i didn't you look great
hey
great pun now grogu as always is a fiend
for them frogs and he almost eats one
but luke says quit yo jabba jabba and
gets him to drop it he then lifts the
frogs like it's an all-you-can-eat
buffet and much in the same way that
luke didn't believe he could lift the
x-wing grogu is mystified by the power
size matters not i would tell my wife
that and this is given lip service by
luke when the pair go for a walk though
it initially seems like groga is jumping
along we do see through luke's hand
movement that it's actually him doing it
grogoose can't jump and later in the
episode luke makes jumping one of his
most important tasks jedi can of course
leap great distances and their training
seed is really really well done now he
talks about yoda and we still know very
little about their species george lucas
purposely kept them ambiguous so that
the species had a mystery surrounding
them and even the way that yoda talked
was unlike any other character just so
that it was almost like a riddle this is
something that luke brings up and he
tries to tap into grogu's memory which
is where we see the events of order 66
playing out on coruscent we still don't
know who saved grogu but there are three
jedi that defend him however all die as
the clone troopers close in i actually
have a feeling that someone else will
jump down and stop him from being
slaughtered but who this is we don't
quite know now as for the jedi that
protect him i believe that this is
syndraleg benny and while melrose
probably pronounce them horribly but the
lightsaber colours of green green and
blue match theirs and it does seem like
the trio benny was also a nod to the
benny jesuit from june who heavily
inspired the jedi order now there might
be an inconsistency here as a hologram
showed anakin cutting through them in
revenge of the sith but yeah i could be
wrong so comment below and let me know
we'll probably learn more about grogu's
history in the mandalorian season 3 but
this is a nice little teaser of what's
to come luke says he'll teach him how to
protect himself and the jedi of course
are known for their defense rather than
their attack i love the phrasing of this
and he also brings up do or do not there
is no try this is something that yoda
said too and the entire training scene
somewhat mirrors the one that luke had
on dagobah he runs with grogu in a
backpack similar to what he did with
yoda but this time he's the master
instead of the apprentice he does the
flip that he also did in an empire and
it's such a great moment you also catch
the laser training remote that luke used
in a new hope and i do wonder if this is
the same model this is something that we
saw younglings using an attack of the
clones to master their abilities and
it's nice that he's brought across this
staple of jedi training into his new
vision now curtin mandel lying on the
bench and at this point he's greeted by
ahsoka she says that she's an old family
friend and was of course anakin's
padawan in the clone wars series we see
that r2 actually brought mano to a
sucker instead of luke as jedi mustn't
really have attachments and therefore
she doesn't really want him to see the
boy we of course know what happened with
anakin and padme and jedi's in love end
up in alderaan places which is it a good
joke i don't know but the mandalorian
are supposed to act as a tribe that care
for one another whereas the jedi kind of
forbid them having any people in their
life that they love is he a foundling is
he a padawan we don't know yet but i
hope that mano gets him out of there
before ben shows up we later get to
confirm that the pouches chainmail armor
in it and as the armor said last week
best score can only be used for defense
and not as a weapon this is because it
could be used on a mandalorian but even
with all that armor they can still have
their heart broken rather than seeing
him mano makes a tough choice not to as
it would interfere with his training and
i i wasn't crying when i watched this
bit now grogu reaches out to his ship as
it leaves and it's a really sad moment
he must find balance in the force and
this is put through into his training
literally in which he must balance
eventually he learns to jump and groga
destroys the training remote through
mastering the force we discover that
he's very much remembering things rather
than learning them and he's clearly
repressed a lot of his memories due to
the trauma that he faced ahsoka brings
luke the grogue package and she tells
him about his father and all of the kids
that he'd killed i'm just kidding you
punk the thumbs down isn't there anymore
there's nothing you can do about it now
ahsoka ends up leaving and she may even
end up joining mando's side as he teams
up with boba in order to stop the pikes
armando is the wielder of the darksaber
but the question remains will he be able
to use it and unite all of the
mandalorians as per the prophecy in
order to wield this he will need
training just like sabine wren as he
finds the dark saber very heavy and this
makes it difficult for him to use
through rebels we learn that it's
something that can only be helped with
training and with mano heading out to
meet grogu there is possibility that
luke will sense something in him
currently there are theories that he's
actually force sensitive and looking at
the full character there's definitely a
possibility he has quick reflexes and
has also managed to survive in
situations that others would perish in
this can be explained as mandalorians
and jedis are natural enemies so he
would have used training to become a
jedi's combat equal however he does have
this raw skill but as luke said in the
season 2 finale talent without training
is nothing and the omra said that his
mind is not focused if he is force
sensitive though then it may explain his
power over being just a highly trained
mandalorian now another clue is that
mando has an incredibly strong
connection with your boy grogu grogu
doesn't really listen to anyone else and
ahsoka struggled to train him hinting
that there may be a strong force bond
between grogu and mando now if this is
the case and he does have these
abilities then it could lead to him
being like the creator of the saber both
a mandalorian and force sensitive and
this would make him somewhat the second
coming of tour he will need the boost of
being force sensitive if as a fouling he
is to sit on the throne of mandalore but
he will need to train to use the saber
first now occur to him returning to
tatooine and can catch the twin sons
from space mandel flies in the jabba's
hangar and you can catch a sail barge at
the entrance which of course appeared in
return of the jedi a gomorian appears
and greets him and after name dropping
fenix shan he's taken to the briefing
room where we see her the mez majordomo
black resentin boba and the mod gang now
as for the gang they're named the mods
which is actually a play on mod culture
in the uk modern star wars means
modification whereas in real life it
meant modernist the bikes the gangs use
are based on lambretta's and though
they're going down worse than a beef big
or at a vegan festival actually do like
the crew now there's been some criticism
that the bikes look stupid and colourful
but this is coming in a time where the
empire had just fallen they pretty much
kept everything uniformed and just like
our own mods rose in the wake of world
war ii these muds have sprung up after
the conflict now fenix says that the
mayor has flown off world to which his
servant says that it was a scheduled
vacation bit of political social
commentary there that we won't go into
but quite a funny line from dave
pasquezi they have enforcers but not
enough for an all-out war and ding-jaren
says that he can help with that code of
the jawas who've mounted the skull of a
crate dragon onto their sand crawler
which is really striking imagery these
giant beasts roam the desert and we of
course saw mano take one down at the end
of season 2 episode 1. i think this
might even be the same skull from that
entry as mando killed it and left the
head intact whoa whoa whoa you can't
park there mate you can't park there but
cobb kind of cools the situation down
for him committed the bar that the pair
met in and we see that the weak way is
still running it this guy is played by
w.l brown who you might recognize from
the series deadwood in that timothy
oliphant played somewhat of a martial in
a way in a way and as always it's all
connected i've been telling you it's all
connected said hundreds of times and you
just start listening now manu tells him
he has to step up or get stepped on as
the syndicate will take over we learn
most palgos has been renamed freetown
which is what it was called in the
expanded little books that first
introduced cobb the townsfolk in these
parts are of course worried that they
could lose it all but cobb tells the
bartender to put out a call we also
catch a banter in the background but the
piece is quickly disturbed by the
arrival of cadbane now this was actually
the biggest moment for me in the episode
and it's so good to see him here this is
the first time he's ever appeared in
live action and though many of us
expected him to arrive in this episode
it was by no means any less cool when he
turned up with him appearing across the
expanded universe he's become a fan
favorite and yeah just watching this
moment it gave me goosebumps now
considering that he's the most wild west
looking bounty hunter it makes sense
that he was introduced in this episode
walking through the desert in a shot
that feels like it was ripped right out
of the good the bad and the ugly now in
case you don't know him he was mented by
jango fett and took his rank as the best
bounty hunter in the galaxy after django
got killed in the battle of genosis
during the clone wars he would work with
other bounty hunters and was notoriously
powerful especially against jedi he was
hired by darth sidious on occasions and
given the job of getting a holocron from
the jedi temple in the later stages of
the war he went on to mentor boba fett
and he trained him during the clone wars
we last saw cad bane in the bad batch
disney plus show where he was hired by
lama sue to hunt down omega she is a
genetically unmodified django clone and
is very much the quote-unquote sister of
boba fett hunting hair brought him into
direct conflict with clone force 99 and
even fenix shan who intercepted the
bounty on here fennec 1 and the pair now
find themselves in opposite factions
once again as cadbane arrives in
freetown working for the pikes now he
says that the pikes will match whatever
fed is willing to pay them and that all
he has to do is stay out of the
situation this very much mirrors the
three-family talk that boba had earlier
in the season and it's clear that they
want people to stay out of the upcoming
war the bear have a quick draw that
feels like it's pulled right out of an
old westin and it's such a cool scene
this was of course murdered in the
opening of the episode when cobb had one
with the pikes but unlike that one he
doesn't come out the winner not only
does bain take down cob he also takes
the new guy out too and announces that
tatooine belongs to the syndicate now we
don't know if cobb is dead and if you
have the subtitles turned on you'll see
that they mention there being something
wrong with him and that he needs help
yeah mate he's just been shot but the
fact that they don't say that he's dead
could mean that he will pop up again
cobb band at this point is a really
light character and i'd love to see him
survive this and show up again curtis
the only bar in the galaxy that will pay
you for polishing your helmet and we see
as the pikes leave an explosive
container behind this is of course very
similar the one at the start of the
entry and it might even be the same
explosive that they picked up there go
to the volleyball temple and luke
presents mando's gift which as many of
you guessed was chainmail armor strong
enough to block a lightsaber it's
something that would be very very
valuable to anyone small enough to wear
it however luke offers him a choice he
can either become like the mandalorian
or like the jedi he then presents him
yoda's lightsaber which does wreck on
how it was destroyed by darth vader in
the comics series i think that the show
is very much dealing with what way that
grogu will go and though we don't see
the outcome of this i think that he will
pick the armor up and return to his dad
the ship of course even has the seat
belt perfectly for him so yeah going
forward that is the way that i think
things will pan out now to my thoughts
on the episode i think this was
outstanding and for me the show gets
better and better every single week they
delivered home run after home run in the
century and it's incredible that we got
this much fan service though the show
has run away from being a boba fett one
i'm still loving it and this is some of
the best star wars i think we've had in
a long time one of the major problems
i've seen said about the show is its
pacing issues as we're dealing with
flashback heavy entries and ones that
don't even feature the titular character
i think that had this been marketed as a
sort of game of thrones story in which
several characters were part of the cast
in order to tell an overarching
narrative that it wouldn't have really
been a problem but as this is the book
of boba fett it's kind of expected that
he should be the one at the front i
haven't really had a problem with it
though and i am excited for the finale
which as next week now as many of you
know my wife is pregnant with twins that
are due to come out in the next two to
three weeks so if i don't have a video
next wednesday then they're probably
either coming or they're already here i
will try and post out as soon as i can
though but i appreciate you bearing with
me now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode so make sure you
comment below and let me know we're
running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the june box
set on the 28th of feb and all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want someone else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the night of a thousand
tears which will be linked on screen
right now we went over the whole thing
and talked about everything you need to
know about it so definitely go check it
out right after this if not then thanks
for sitting through the video i've been
paul you've been the best i'll see you
on the next one take care peace